he was the first african-american
billionaire he's a businessman media
magnate philanthropist and investor he's
worth over a half a billion dollars he's
Robert Johnson and here are his top ten
rules for success fundamental connection
to doing businesses basically
relationships you know people really if
you really think about it people want to
do business with people they like I mean
every now and then you'll do a deal with
the devil but you don't really like the
devil but you have do it sometimes but
you really much rather do business with
somebody you like somebody who shares
your values somebody who you know is
committed to the same objectives you are
somebody's willing to work as hard as
you are and when you find those people
those are the people you want to bring
under your tent to be part of your
business objective and you've got to do
that by you know sort of presenting
yourself in a way that people clearly
understand that you are committed to
creating value business people want to
create value it doesn't mean they won't
want to have fun doesn't mean that they
don't want to be involved in other kinds
of things but if you can say go to
someone and convince them that I can
help you create value and by your
ability to articulate that and to
communicate it and to give people the
impression that you will work as hard as
they will to create that value you're
gonna find people wanting to come to you
and so for me it's sort of been like
that throughout my whole career is being
able to to say to people and what talk
to people in a way that convinces them
that I am going to do everything I can
to help make what they want to achieve a
success and by extension I'm going to be
a success when I started a bgt the guy
who invested in BET's a guy named John
Maloney
he was at that time the operator the
third largest cable company in Denver
Colorado and he kept investing money and
to be et without taking additional
equity and as Beatty became a big
success you
I ended up with about 75% of the company
he ended up about 25% of the company and
one day I asked him I said to John John
you you put over a half a million
dollars in BTD on the startup you put it
in his debt you didn't put it in his
equity which would give them greater
ownership I said why'd you do it that
way and he said Bob I always knew you
would work harder for yourself than you
would for me and it was that kind of
commitment so if you can convey to
people that you're willing to work hard
for them and for yourself you've got his
business partner you're connecting the
dots one of the key components of
growing a business is getting the
necessary capital to grow so if you
start off where you own a hundred
percent but you need more capital to
grow the business you may have to sell
off 20% 30% depending on how you look at
the business needs don't fear that don't
don't be afraid about the notion that
you might fall below 51% and therefore
not be minority-owned because being
minority-owned is the culture you said
is the focus you said it's the service
you make to serve the minority community
and it's your commitment to do what you
can do best within the minority
community keep in mind if you go back to
a JPMorgan Chase
Jamie Dimon probably owns less than zero
zero five percent of change he's the CEO
because he yes but no one ever
questioned whether or not he's in charge
of chase but he's brought in capital as
a publicly traded company to grow that
business so whether you get money from
outside investors or whether you get
money from friends or family don't be
afraid to take on capital sell [ __ ] sell
shares or restructure debt or trade
preferred or common whatever it is
because the notion is you want to be in
charge of a growth company if that's
what you want to be a company that can
go to scale a company that compete and
you need capital to grow so don't if you
want to stay up up if you want percent
by all means if you can do it and don't
sell your equity off do it but if you if
you have to because you got a great
the cheating partner that could bring
something to the table and they want to
be an equity player and you end up with
50 or less than 50
you're still the CEO you're still
setting the vision for the company you
are achieving what you set out to do and
I think that's very important to
understand because we can't get the
scale without growth capital I may not
be smart but I'm not stupid so I got to
check first and then I said John I've
never started a business what advice can
you give me so but I had to check by
then he said Bob get your revenues up
keep your costs down
okay that was my 501 business school
class and ever since that time every
business I start revenues up cost down
that's what I do all right
thanks big business is where you get
your revenues up keep your costs down
and if you can find a recurring income
stream like a cable company called BT
the guys pay you that cable operators
pay you for the programming the
advertisers pay you to advertise within
the program and the record companies
give you the videos free you'd have to
be pretty dumb to lose money on a
business like that
so the key to building relationship and
so-called connecting the dots is make
your friends before you need them and
that means that first impression that
first interaction you have with somebody
is sort of like a stamp of approval and
if you do that with someone and they
like you and then they in turn tell
somebody else they like you that's where
the dots start coming because somebody
will say I know
Dameon good guy so I respect the guy who
told me that so all of a sudden now he's
transferred his stamp of approval on you
over to me and that's how it happens the
one thing I think we have to do is we've
got to get smart about consumption we
have got to start saving when I went to
graduate school at at Princeton and I
took one course in economics and there's
one term that I learned it's called and
you guys should remember this one it's
called the marginal propensity to
consume the marginal propensity to
consume is that you consume way beyond
your Marg
well and you know what they called it
dead we have more debt than any other
group in America ergo we have less
savings without savings
you can't invest without investment you
can't accumulate well we have got to
postpone sort of what I call just
unnecessary impulsive consumption and
focus on savings and until we get to
that point we're not going to have
enough wealth to invest as most of you
know I have always been vocal about
economic opportunity for African
Americans I am what you might call a
serial entrepreneur I get a vision about
something that should be done usually in
an area where African Americans are
economically and underrepresented and I
try my best to create a business
solution to help address these social
and economic problems people here in the
same business I mean if you're running
the same business of somebody else the
first thing I would do is sit down and
talk about can we merge and get to scale
that's the first thing I would do
there's no way in the world if I were
running a company let's say I was in the
security business providing security to
companies and then there's another guy
named Freddy who had a security company
on another guy named and a person named
Marriott of security to come three
security companies all vying for the
contracts I would say why don't we merge
get the scale reduce our overhead costs
and go out and become the preeminent
security firm in the City of Charlotte
there is no way in the world I would be
competing against that that's the first
thing I would do you have to believe in
yourself if you don't believe in
yourself if you don't believe that you
can overcome obstacles if you don't
believe you have the work ethic if you
don't believe you have the inner
confidence to project to other people
it'll never happen because part of
starting a business
not having not only having the vision of
an idea you've got to build around you a
team of stakeholders who believe in you
people follow leaders people invest in
leaders people support people who have a
vision and are willing to and are able
to articulate it and not just the
ability you know a lot of people could
have got a good gift for gab it's the
ability to convince people that you're
going to be part of something that's
going to be successful you're going to
share in the success it's going to be
beneficial to you and your family in the
long run you're going to be respected
for what you contribute and you're going
to have an opportunity to fulfill your
own dreams consistent with the dreams
the person you're working with if you
can convey that sense of confidence and
that consent because that sense of
leadership and focus on giving people an
opportunity to grow and be successful
with you you're gonna have people enemy
really smart people coming to be a part
of what you do imagine a group of people
go to a restaurant and they started well
they don't have enough money to pay the
bill so when the waiter comes with the
bill that they don't want to pay it they
don't make the sacrifice of pay so they
keep ordering and that's what we're
doing we just keep piling on debt and
keep piling on costs because we don't
want to make the hard choices look at
businesses who have who can provide
support to your business at a cost below
what you're paying somebody else and if
you don't have the money
tip for that but it'll help you
jump-start your business give them
equity trade equity for the service
provider it happens all the time when I
start a BT I need a cable distribution
some of the cable time-warner at that
time said yeah we'd like to be an
investment but we also want equity we'll
give you our carriage but we want equity
and that's another way to build a
relationship doesn't take capital just
you gotta behave confident but when you
provide a service that service is going
to help this
business grow you have 10% equity
whatever the trade is help you grow
thank you for watching I made this video
because Frank white asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know what you think
of Robert Johnson and which of the top
10 lessons you relate to the most leave
it below I'm going to join the
discussion
thank you for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon